[Music]
in 1962 a cave Explorer named Michel
Seif started a series of experiments
where he isolated himself underground
for months without light or clocks he
attached himself to electrodes that
monitored his vital signs and kept track
of when he slept and ate when C finally
emerged the results of his pioneering
experiments revealed that his body had
kept to a regular sleeping waking cycle
despite having no external cues he fell
asleep woke up and ate at fixed
intervals this became known as a
circadian rhythm from the Latin for
about a day scientists later found these
rhythms affect our hormone secretion how
our body's process food and even the
effects of drugs on our bodies the field
of science is studying these changes is
called chronobiology being able to sense
time helps us do everything from waking
and sleeping to knowing precisely when
to catch a ball that's hurtling towards
us we owe all these abilities to an
interconnected system of timekeepers in
our brains
it contains the equivalent of a
stopwatch telling us how many seconds
elapsed a clock counting the hours of
the day and a calendar notifying us of
the seasons each one is located in a
different brain region sieve stuck in
his dark cave relied on the most
primitive clock in the suprachiasmatic
nucleus or SCN of the hypothalamus
here's the basics of how we think it
works based on fruit fly and mouse
studies proteins known as CLK or clock
accumulate in the SCM throughout the day
in addition to activating genes that
tell us to stay awake they make another
protein called purr when enough purr
accumulates it deactivates the gene that
makes clock eventually making us fall
asleep then clock falls low Soper
concentrations also drop again allow
clock to rise starting the cycle over
there are other proteins involved but
our day and night cycle may be driven in
part by this seesaw effect between clock
by day and / by night for more precision
our SC NS also rely on external cues
like light food noise and temperature we
call these site gamers German for givers
of time C lacked many of these cues
underground but in normal life they fine
tune our daily behavior for instance as
natural morning light filters into our
eyes it helps wake us up traveling
through the optic nerve to the SCN it
communicates what's happening in the
outside world the hypothalamus then
halts the production of melatonin a
hormone that triggers sleep at the same
time it increases the production of
vasopressin
and noradrenaline throughout the brain
which help control our sleep cycles at
about 10 a.m. the body's rising
temperature drives up our energy and
alertness and later in the afternoon it
also improves our muscle activity and
coordination bright screens at night can
confuse these signals which is why
binging on TV before bed makes it harder
to sleep but sometimes we need to be
even more precise when telling the time
which is where the brains internal
stopwatch chimes in one theory for how
this works involves the fact that
communication between a given pair of
neurons always takes roughly the same
amount of time so neurons in our cortex
and other brain areas may communicate in
scheduled predictable loops that the
cortex uses to judge with precision how
much time has passed that creates our
perception of time in his cave seif made
a fascinating additional discovery about
this everyday he challenged himself to
count up to 120 at the rate of one digit
per second
over time instead of taking two minutes
it began taking him as long as five life
in the lonely dark cave had warped
Steve's own perception of time
despite his brains best efforts to keep
him on track this makes us wonder what
else influences our sense of time and if
time isn't objective what does that mean
could each of us be experiencing it
differently only time will tell
[Music]
you